today's topic so
a couple of months back we did a video
in regards to logan paul going to i
believe was like
ibiza so
he went there and came to find out all
the beautiful women that we're seeing
were instagram models who were basically
being pimped out uh for money and a lot
of people were shocked they couldn't
believe it but we ended up doing a video
showcasing how some instagram models
sell off their services to go to dubai
to go do their thing get involved with
kids 13 year olds they'll do whatever
for money and here's the thing i just
want to start by saying this
personally if people want to go do this
kind of work there's not an issue go
ahead all right my main issue with this
whole scene and this is the thing
when folks get on instagram and they see
these ladies living their best lives
traveling the world these girls always
make it sound like yeah everything's
business
yeah i'm doing this thing strong
independent meaningless like some dubai
prince is like inviting her out doing
some of the most nasty things in the
world and she's doing it for a bit of
cash so there's a a bit of a
desperation and a selling of self in
order to be able to live the lifestyle
that they advertise in a certain type of
way so that's the stuff that kind of
makes me look funny it's like dudes who
do this whole bodybuilding thing you're
like oh i'm nerdy i'm nadia netti come
to find out they're sticking themselves
with all kinds of stuff yeah right and
that has a lot of um
influence on young dudes you got 15 16
year olds trying to get their access to
trend so that they can look like that
because they know the truth right so
it's important to be transparent about
both the positive and the downsides of
this i'm not telling people not to do it
if you want to sell yourself to a dubai
prince and turn into a porta potty live
your best life
okay but just know that it can [ __ ] with
you mentally yeah if you want to meet
the scat man go ahead let's give it to
me
that's you this is a conversation
okay that one instagram model had with a
supposed dubai prince or who she
believed was the dubai part so we got
this erica lady she was offered 50k
uh one week in dubai banged every day
let me see
someone should read it you want to read
it sure sure
all right read the the top
what year it's 2014 2015. um okay
it's nice but i have
a car already better give me 50 000.
okay girl live your life
i can give you 50 but you must also make
my camel happy
camel she says
up
top
i'll put
i'll put hummus
arab food around your anus
and boobs then my camel would lick
you
with this thong
yes
let's do it
zero [ __ ] giving with this person hold
up and then she and then he says
would you sleep with the camel she said
yes
she said and then he says 50k but no car
and then her reply
let me tell her that camel's bite can
buy this
no i train him to respect women
very good boy
get the [ __ ] out of here oh my god very
good boy
okay lol jesus christ that's crazy
but yeah that's the world we live it'll
get worse oh no we're not living no he
says we can do aids test in dubai get
the results on the same day
i'll urinate
let me rephrase
i will golden shower
let me rephrase i will
golden stream
inside your mouth
and head
i will only
poop
on your boobs and back 40k usd
and she says no that's too much
you want more money or you want a car
she says money and card
he says you like it
this is your car yes but i don't like it
i only use six times
whoever is writing this dialogue
it's using broken english on purpose
and he's making it like
he's watched enough movies
yes but i don't like
i only use six times
i'm consent and i understand why i'm
coming to you and i'm okay with your
fetish and i promise to give
confidentiality
this is real real yeah just to make sure
that people don't come back to them
or they or make sure they don't have to
make you disappear
but there's one in particular from a
girl who i believe she's from australia
and her name is saneed
mcnamara
okay so she worked on a 140 million
dollar mcnamara
mcnamara yeah
okay she worked on 140 million mayan
queen super yacht touring europe greece
specifically okay and she's basically
working as a server as a waitress she's
an instagram model she's brought on
as a worker
on her last shift she was found dead
body hanging from the back of the yacht
now this is where things get a little
bit squirrely because uh
reportedly she had a fight with someone
on the yacht the day before her death
how do we know this
miss mcnamara called her mother the day
before she was found dead to complain
that she had been in an argument with
someone on board eiza was yelling and
she was being hysterical phone kind of
cut out the next day she's found gone
the authorities come on this border of
this billionaire super yacht and they
say no foul play she took her own life
suspicious undoubtedly did foul play
happen no way to know
but
you mean the police came in a place
where they can be bought
by on a plane of a militant
multi-millionaire
billionaire billionaire and nothing was
found
sweeped under the rug yes everything is
all good exactly and kosher
kids close
all right
so you have to imagine when you're
getting flown around and you're sent to
go see these super rich people who have
enough money to make you disappear like
nothing who have enough political
influence to make your disappearance
disappear
politically
political influence
they're the politics
they run some of these countries they're
the hands behind a puppet exactly so the
dark side of a lot of people is like
sometimes people just disappear you
never hear from them again yeah right
so there's you're talking about it
you're talking to a dude that is from
haiti
there are stories of ig models or these
ladies who go to these places and just
disappear
that's real to get a 50k bag sounds
great
the dark side is also potentially there
depending on who you're getting involved
with because guess what some of these
people have violent tendencies because
they're bored
because they're bored yeah the whole
like pooping in the mouth and doing all
this other stuff
[ __ ] you're bored yeah i don't want to
keep doing the whole camel stuff because
there's a lot of camel stuff like these
people do something to dogs camels 12
year old kids they'll do a legal [ __ ]
they don't give a [ __ ] go ahead if it's
paid they'll do it
and
when they're glorifying their life
they're taking these pictures in these
jets ask yourself what did they do to
get there you know how much that's the
spot that they'll never talk about you
know how much it costs to go there
do you know how much it costs to live
around there
yeah well those are always there you've
been once i don't care if you're always
there
meal and [ __ ] if you're if if you're not
a stewardess
then okay
okay
yeah
it seems nice and everything the drinks
the life the bottles the meals
the luxury life
when the bill comes someone's gonna have
to cash it
and it's your butt butt do you remember
that actress from twilight katie
something or kate uh
yeah what's her name
the actress from twilight you know she
got offered five hundred thousand
dollars to meet with the dubai prince
for 15 minutes
do you want to know who set it up
who said it
weinstein oh
god
so why am i saying all this i'm just
saying a lot of these ig models that you
guys look up to
they're getting paid
and they got a price in a lot of cases
oh well kim k was upfront as well a
million dollars by dubai prince
some of them take it okay some of them
definitely take that money so all this
to say just to wrap all this up there's
a lot of safety issues in regards to
this there's a lot of i think
unhealthiness in general but if people
want to make these choices they should
be free to make them but i just want you
guys to know so when you guys are on
instagram and y'all seen these dubai
trips you're doing all these private
jets understand
who's the sponsor mm-hmm
whatever
whenever you see girls on the boat and
you never see the dude that's piloting
the boat
some girl got mad at me she's like maybe
she paid for her own trip to dubai
[Music]
sure
okay you see a table dinner for two you
never see the dude
i was born at night
i was not born last night damn right so
anyways just wanted to do this video as
a part two because a lot of you guys
were asking there's a lot of tragic
stories like these so if you guys want
to look into it i'm sure you can find
them yourselves but that is it for
today's video let us know what you guys
think
do you guys believe
a lot of these people are not doing this
stuff or do you believe a lot of them
are engaging in it
maybe we're wrong maybe you're right let
us know in the comments below and if you
enjoyed today's video leave a like and a
comment
helps out that algorithm
oh and part three
um we're going to be interviewing just
camels okay camels with hummus on their
feet
that's nice audrey's gonna be uh uh
rappers in fake jewelry